this movie doesn't make sense this movie
doesn't make sack welcome back to things
you missed last time we covered Pet
Sematary this time I'm taking on the
movie only sequel Pet Sematary - the way
the logo is animated calls back to the
blue light that shines from the Mi'kmaq
burial grounds in the first one but the
actual tone of the movie does not remind
me of the first one it opens on a
Hollywood movie set where this woman is
reaching to open a coffin at scene it's
a little bit of a hint that maybe her
coffin is gonna be pried open later on
but before she can open it this hand
reaches for her as part of the horror
movie that they're filming and later on
we get a better look at that prop it
looks exactly like the hand that
appeared a couple years before hand in
it I later found out that it actually is
the same exact prop so props to them for
reusing that pun intended
another Stephen King reference can be
seen on the slate which displays the
title of this movie within the movie
castle of Terror it could be a reference
to Castle Rock which is the location in
Maine that shows up in a bunch of
Stephen King novels and later got its
own TV show 33 takes
yikes maybe Rene was lucky to have
gotten the early ticket off that set
what I want to know is who saw this
woman getting electrocuted and decided
you know what I'm gonna knock over this
one kay just to add to the noise we then
meet Rene's husband who is a
veterinarian which I found interesting
because Louis from the first movie
specifically says that he's not a vet at
one point this kid has to make the
decision to put down his beloved dog and
dr. Matthews is faced with a similar
decision at the end of the movie so then
like two hours after the funeral of his
wife dr. Matthews is already checking
out this attractive young housekeeper
he'd been able to keep his eyes off of
her he would have noticed the name of
the moving company Mayflower
historically the Mayflower was the name
of one of the ships that brought the
first European settlers to America these
settlers ended up driving away the
Native American groups that already
lived there and this movie is basically
about white settlers defiling an ancient
Indian burial ground but I'm with dr.
Matthews on this one the hot shake is
much more interesting to look at she
almost gets killed by a box of Rene's
stuff
[Music]
which sets up her eventually later
getting killed by Rene herself dr.
Matthews Sun and Jeff tags along as he
goes to work where he basically sums up
the entire movie isn't too bad for
example here's a newspaper from Coweta
Georgia where they filmed the movie even
though it's supposed to take place in
Maine
the town sheriff brings his stepson to
get his dog Zowie checked out by the new
doc even though he ends up shooting the
dog the very next night so what was the
point of bringing him to the vet if he
wanted him dead I just don't understand
the logic there also
Jeff tries to bring his cat to school
and it gets taken by the bullies I only
bring it up because I'll probably never
get to use the word catnap again and
because you might have missed this
display dedicated to Jeff's mother I
guess it makes sense that she'd be kind
of a hero in such a small town if she
made it as a b-list actress in Hollywood
also when the bullies are running away
you can get a little glimpse of the
mascot of the junior high school
it's the Lumberjacks which may be
another reference to the Native American
versus European settlers theme that I
mentioned earlier during the bike chase
that ensues they ride by the Creed house
even though it looks nothing like the
house from the first movie then Jeff
goes to look for the cat in a pet
cemetery that looks nothing like the pet
cemetery also the deadfall looks nothing
like the deadfall from the first one
it also doesn't make sense how the main
bully clyde parker which is an excellent
name for a bully by the way had time to
hide the cat all the way in the pet
cemetery I mean the Jeff and the sheriff
son Drew were on his tail the entire
time like I don't know when that
happened but anyway Jeff finds his cat
and he and drew bond over a mutual
dislike for their step parents / sexy
housekeeper basically stepmom kind of
thing the first day school is always the
hardest you're not my mother
Jeff and drew gotta bury Zowie at this
point you probably shouldn't be
surprised that it looks nothing like the
burial ground from the first one in the
following scene we see the inside of
Drew's room I'm guessing he's supposed
to be from Seattle or something because
he's got a poster for Seafarer which
takes place in Seattle and there's a
Mariners panniers door this could also
be part of the reason that he and Jeff
become friends both being transplants
from the West Coast though it's not
explained at all during the movie
his parents are at the door to let him
know that Zowie is back and his mom
gives dr. Matthews a call to take a look
at it
walls away is staying in the Matthews
house he turns up in the middle of the
night in Jeff's room looking all
scp-1472 one the next part takes place
on Halloween which was good to see
because the first Pet Sematary movie
skips over Halloween but in the book
it's actually an important scene where
judge Randall's wife Norma has a heart
attack and Lewis saves her life an event
that Judd would later cite as part of
the reason they felt that he had to help
Lewis survive his daughter's cast by
introducing him to the Mi'kmaq burial
ground
Clyde Parker gives everyone an IMDB
summary of the first movie and ghost
story form as they sit around a fire at
the pet cemetery when the sheriff comes
up and breaks up the party so he can
punish his son with a little bit of
domestic violence but Zowie comes to the
rescue and tears his frickin throat out
this is where things just to go off the
rails Jeff and drew have a sudden change
of heart and decide to bring the sheriff
back using the mcnac grounds he comes
back as a much nicer guy for some reason
I guess that's what happens when the
person who dies is already more evil
than the wendigo back in dr. Matthews
his office he gets back the results of
his always blood tests which say the
blood came from a dead animal as the
ironic natural life pet products sign
hangs over his head yeah there's nothing
natural about this dago's life anymore
wait wait hold on right there and play
that back
does he just start casually eating dog
treats what is wrong with this guy I
mean I've accidentally eaten a dog treat
before and let me just say they're not
good dr. Matthews discovers that Zowie
has escaped and stops by the school to
let Jeff and drew know does anyone else
think that these two deserve their own
mm Nickelodeon sitcom dr. Matthews goes
to visit the former Ludlow veterinarian
who's taken up taxidermy sounds like the
villain of a whole nother horror movie
but he goes to ask about the dead animal
blood the old vet tells him that this
happened once before with the Creed's
cat Church from the first movie Church
does go to the vet to get fixed but
that's before he died and there's no
indication of Lewis taking him to the
vet after that the old vet does have a
pair of antlers mounted on his door
which could be this movie's tiny
one-two-go reference just like the
mantelpiece in Judds room was in the
first one meanwhile the sheriff isn't
trying to kill anyone but he's
completely lost it
yeah while Jeff is over at Drew's house
for dinner and dr. Matthews salts and
grievance watching some of the movies
that his wife was in this is actually a
real movie that the actress who played
Renee was in called Once Upon a Time in
America I'm kind of impressed that they
didn't just take the whole Bride of
Chucky Road and just have Dan Lane
flugel in the movie as herself the next
day after Josh and just did that the
next day after Jeff and drew get done
hanging out and being angsty drew
notices excellently named bully Clyde
Parker coming after his friend and
performs one of the most impressive
athletic feats in cinema history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the best part is that's actually the
music Clyde has some weird fascination
with bike spoke related injuries there's
a little accident she's trying to get
away cause the spokes and just before
Jeff's face gets chopped up he's
inexplicably saved by a zombie sheriff
who then completely does a 180 and
starts killing everyone he sees I never
claimed that this movie made sense he
temporarily turns into Jack Torrance
from The Shining
[Music]
here's Johnny
hey you know it's strange and Pet
Sematary the road is constantly filled
with passing trucks in fact it's kind of
like a main points of that movie but
we've seen plenty of road shots and
there hasn't been one single trip oh
wait I see what's gonna happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the sheriff decides to revive Clyde
and ranae for some reason I mean he does
explain why he wants Renae but at this
point it really just seems like he's
doing random stuff the only thing I
found that seems to kind of explain his
behavior is that the wendigo never
actually appeared in the first movie so
it seems like maybe director Mary
Lambert could be going for a demonic
possession type of thing instead this
Krauss that's usually up right in the
sheriff's house is now inverted and it
looks like he went a little crazy with
the chainsaw off screen and the
lawnmower I'm not sure if this is
supposed to be a reference or not but
the way Jeff is sitting in this chair
reminds me a lot of Claire from Black
Christmas and this movie ends the same
way as the first one essentially with
all the zombies showing up and then
dying in a fire except this time the
fire is started by the zombies the
sheriff goes through all this trouble to
bring these people back and then they
basically just want to die again there's
a clear chance for Renee to escape right
here but she just wants them to stay as
she burns in a fire so I'll wrap this
video up how I started it by saying this
movie makes no sense but we're not done
with pet cemetery yet because the remake
is coming out in just a couple weeks so
check out the video on the left to hear
about the complete history of the pet
cemetery Wendigo and make sure you
subscribe to see ZZZ world to hear about
all the things you might have missed in
the 2019 pet cemetery ring the death
bell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one assuming we both
survived
[Music]